I went into US Angeles to a bookstore
and I bought a whole bunch of these and
some of them I guess you can tell why
they didn't do well there's this one
right here it's called the big book of
people who never found Waldo and it's
just a hold these people are really
depressed look at that guy never found
Walter it's just really Debrett kid
sister all of them yeah and there's a
guy well that's yeah that's just a cheap
joke and I can't believe we did it
oh that's a book yeah Joe we didn't do
it a book get it here's one if seen
Coffeyville book it's called the product
placement in old movies I don't know if
remember in Casablanca when they were
promoting Foot Locker horsten Gone with
the Wind we have that nice little
Starbucks promotion right there
everybody talked about yeah and then of
course down here I like this book a lot
I don't know why it didn't sell what's
called stuff built out of Legos by dumb
kids
mr. today station right there la branche
look at that $400 kid yeah and then yeah
zoo look at this book right here it's
called are you my dad senator Ted Cruz
by Corey Feldman
just a lot of yeah it's just a lot of
pictures of the
I never thought about it but Ted Cruz
has a lot of questions again I don't
know why this one didn't sell I think
this would have been great guys you just
know have clammy hands I don't even have
to shake his hand to know this and then
it's not good all right I hope they're
watching all right you of course
familiar with the st. Bernard know that
do good deeds and they bring yeah
they're like rescue dog rescue dogs well
this one is a book called unsane T Saint
Bernards these are st. Bernards
there are less than of my god they
really really look at this one bringing
cyanide to people good and then look at
this curve right they're looking at nude
humans this one's a little different
it's called y'all ready for dis that's
right she's ready not ready
ready and then ready and then
Oh laying in bed just resting she's
comfy yeah she's gonna be around for a
long time not ready okay this is an
interesting one a lot of Star Wars fans
out there yeah yeah this one's called
that's in here yeah and in here too at
least listen to this Star Wars character
prom photo look at that yeah there's
Lando Calrissian and Janus right there
tonight yeah look at this one right here
there's Chewbacca and his sister yeah no
one else to go with him and art to teach
you and a dorm fridge
[Applause]
I hear those dorm fridges are easy oh
yeah they're [ __ ] all right and finally
dad's of One Direction fans reacting to
Zane's departure
[Applause]
forget hard
you